, alright.
A huge
week in politics and I wanna hear from people
on the phones.
6178304750 is the number.
Let's go
first.
Oh, I wanna check in with Dante from Florida,
who I wanna see where "Dantes head is at,
Dante.
How are you doing today with everything going
on?
Oh boy, last night was a bad night to tell
you, not a one­speaker phone please, please,
please take a
soft speaker phone.
I'm not on a speaker phone, I'm in a background.
The rest, Rolfe.
Alright, sounds good.
So, out, he finds what I wanna stay with bernstor.
It's not
done the races and over yet so I see a lot
of people mature trying to call it and trying
to end the
debate and put them into the primary just
because sidings, from the number that I've
seen, it looks
like by Brian has 4­9% of votes deleted to
win the nomination on the first Malian.
Bernie is about
46% so the race is still pretty close, even
though by didn't as a lease.
That being said, it's in
conversation about whether or not people who
support "Brandis for you by Pelton.
I just wanted for
my position on that out there for...
Well, I definitely would not be voted for
you by a cyanosis.
We because if I...
Yeah, so do I, let alteration let's...
I think I get it.
Let's talk through each piece.
First of all, which states do you think give
Bernie a path to the nomination, it's gonna
be tough.
There's a lot of things that can happen before
each states both Lorde might become, but is
it the
base before Florida?
So we're gonna have to see you by insofar
two hours go head head with bring
Sanders.
And had he not done well in any debate?
So, in, in the debate when he has more air
time,
you're gonna do it with worse.
So that could definitely help or understand
it's out in losing how a lot
of the states that voted there's been big
changes in people's mind.
The 48 hours before the rotation
to a...
I understand your point, do you agree that
all of the states in which a lot of people
decided in
the last 48 hours, all of those states, went
to bid and you know that, right?
No, I'm not talking just about this primary
the last Super today, but also blame whatever.
But the
point I'm trying to make is there are things
that can happen before the primaries that
got it
charming, it gotta go Okay, hey, a lot.
I Teotihuacan, think Bernie's done, and I've
given the math work, but we don't have to
argue we'll
know in a few days.
Here's what I wanna talk to you about.
You say bins the nominee you won't vote for
bid.
And so,
here's just my go hold the guy.
Are you "donta 2­3 In A...
Okay, and am I correct to assume you
don't have children currently yes, okay, I
just wanna lay out this scenario 'cause this
is the one that
makes me realize I have to vote for Joe Biden.
I imagine that Ruth Bader Ginsburg is not
gonna be
on the Supreme Court until January of 2025,
I think it's likely that she will leave the
Supreme
Court, sometime between now and during the
next Presidential term in imagine that 20
years from
now, I have a teenager, and the person Trump
picked to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg is the
7th
conservative vote on a Supreme Court.
That is making decisions every week that affect
a teenager,
that I have in 15 or 20 years, I can't live
with that, I can't live with that.
The person Joe Biden would
replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg with who will
make Supreme Court decisions for the next
20­30 or 40
03/13/20 Page 4 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
years is going to radically alter the life
of that future teenager.
I don't yet have in a way that it would
be immoral for me to take any action that
makes it likely Trump gets to replace that,
that's just
Supreme Court Justice on.
Do you care about that?
Yeah, yeah, but I think that argument is kind
of another proportion because currently the
Supreme
Court, even the justices that are picked by
Democrats, they're fairly corporates and right
wing and
they signed off on of a bunch of the terrible
Supreme Court decisions.
itineraries or it made the
relations to...
Sure, but some of the conservative justices
have been on the right side of certain
issues too, but for the most part, they haven't
really been much of the opposition on the
court, like I
said, corporate consolidation money in politics,
they just come down on the wrong side of all
those
issues.
I am a you totally.
Or the Manabu again, the point more than that,
but...
And not that it was from
you in the Polity worse, yeah, marginally
worse.
But, on the policies people have this assumption
that Joe Biden is, just by definition, objectively
better than would be better than Donald Trump.
I'm not saying it would be for one from ever.
What you're seeing you be my...
You might not or you might vote.
Third party it Dont...
Let me
give you a second example.
So the Supreme Court is not...
Let me give you one other example just
to hear from you.
Okay, Donald, treatment.
So you got that.
I just, I...
Because we have this is such a...
It's a finite issue.
And I wanna get to just
one more example and hear your thought, and
then we'll have to...
We'll have to move on on the
environment.
Donald Trump has pulled us out of the Paris
Climate Accord, Donald Trump believes that
climate
changes of Hoke created by the Chinese Donald
Trump is relaxing pollution guidelines for
vehicles
Bernini and both support the Green New Deal.
How can you start justify any action that
makes it
more likely? Trump gets to do his climate
plan rather than "bian who supports the Green
New Deal.
How do you support it morally and ethically
or on job does not support the greens.
If you does say
that.
check his website, I check it.
But he also has fossil field executives playing
a huge part in
campaign so I highly doubt that even if he
was elected thing that he's gonna run on support
the
Green­e deal, if you quickly turn on that
I...
So I got a A and I would also...
Teething "yuvan
administration that oversaw the largest co­production
in the United States while we already knew
we were in the primate CICS.
I'm not arguing with you, he's not a poll.
What I'm going to make you...
We're in equal primate power, whether you
"bissett resides on a tent.
Think you're trialling it, but I don't think
it's trivial, to say, Do you...
What about the point that at a
"Bodmin station that...
Yeah, I know, I know, it's a...
The Teatro was not the height of progressivism.
I'm not suggesting it
03/13/20 Page 5 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
is.
All I'm saying is the options will be Trump
provided "bian supports the Green New Deal
and the
Paris Climate Agreement and thinks climate
change is real.
Trump doesn't...
The choice is clear for me, I can't, for my
future children I can't take any action
that makes it more likely Trump gets another
four years of Econ, of environmental destruction.
You
and I just might differ on that.
That's okay, I'm not mad at you done it.
Yeah, he retained I'm not
matter.
Yeah, I just wanna make this one less for
it.
Yeah, in the theoretical analysis of foods
better who's not better, it's it's set be
really all I support
you by over Trump.
But let me just say on Policy, on their record
Joe Biden has been a bill to
people like me, I cannot vote for somebody
like you buy in as a black man who has passed
some of
the most racial racist in winter, a community
of like the Crime Bill Masterton he still
against Leiria
a...
If I Boolean he has no problem lacking of
people like myself who are people of color
who may
smoke.
We may have it on them, and that in rely a
morons also.
You work the bankruptcy.
Did that
made it impossible unobtainable gotten those
in angel?
So you're going from one thing to another
and not even really giving an opportunity
to discuss it.
You're completely right about Joe Biden position
on cannabis.
You're right that years ago, "bian did
support that crime bill but the choice now
is he wrote an Civil and he was on to, with
most seers he
sounded like do some on the floor of congress
calling people you about black people and
calling
them super predators.
And so we need to lock them up and all of
those things done.
I can't vote for
somebody like that.
Don't you know I love you but you just have
to be okay that your actions will
get Trump re­elected, if you're okay with
that that, that's cool.
I listen, I'll deal with whatever I don't
buy it in what you Trump­related.
I wouldn't do anything I would do a such thing.
It would be Joe,
by in his business policy record and his corruption
that led people not to vote for him.
It's not on the
voters to just come out and support anybody
just because they're not on no Trump, that's
right, you.
It is a Trump.
If Joe Ian's position on climate and judges
were worse than trumps then I wouldn't
vote for...
But his position is better.
And one last one I made Cristobal made a great
point about this today, and she said that
the
reason...
One of the reasons why the Democratic party,
like the pander to the so­call centres and
the
moderate Republican is because they fear that
they might not get their vote in the another.
In a real to...
That I saw that tweet.
Here's my reaction.
It's not that they're pandering to the
moderates they are way more moderate.
The Democratic Party is a more moderate or
they don't.
Interrupt is a retaining begging you not to
interrupt me, I'm gonna have to let you go
down to,
actually, but that's enough.
But here's the point.
The Democratic Party is way to right the
Democratic Party.
Well it's quiet all of a sudden I like it.
I can hear myself think, the Democratic
Party is way more moderate than a lot of progressives
like me.
Want to believe when you look at
what is a 15 million vote margin forbid an
over­Bernie.
It's just not nearly as progressive that's
the
reality, it's not pandering to moderates,
its moderates voting for a moderate.
I don't like it but it's the
reality.